these children listen intently to what
the headman of namatakula village has to
say
jose vara nagasakula says he fears the
next generation won't be able to call
this place their home
the hardest thing if you move to another
side it called
it's going to be a different lifestyle
altogether maybe when we move to another
side maybe we're going to move with a
new culture
so we're going to lose our culture
fiji declared a climate emergency last
year with this small village on the
island's coral coast deemed at risk
rising sea levels mean the 600 people
who live here may have to relocate
inland or to a higher ground
but the community is determined to stay
put to protect their homes ancestral
history and culture
which has produced an unprecedented
number of international sports stars
rugby has contributed so much not only
for laser sports but for our economic
achievements villagers head
and our social development
they're all part of our record
fiji's fast unpredictable and exciting
style play is said to be deeply rooted
in the island's cultural motto of vacuum
venal which means the way of the land
some say playing on these beaches is
what sets them apart but what was once
the training ground for aspiring rugby
players has now been washed away the
places where they used to play rugby it
was normally sandy beaches for about 100
meters and 50 meters wide normally we
play there i came across that during the
time that we play in those beaches but
today it's gone because of this climate
change and increase in sea level
rugby is a national obsession in fiji
nearly 10 percent of the island nation's
900 000 people are registered rugby
players one of the highest per capita in
the world
but rugby is more than just a game here
it's a way for men and women to earn a
living wage
climate change is expected to displace
nearly 1.7 million people across the
pacific islands in the next 30 years
and for many fijians the risk of losing
their ancestral lands would be too much
to bear
think of us
think of the small nations in the
pacific oceans especially fiji
especially in our village
because as jose vara nagasakula says
there really is no place like home